the successor to baker mayfield at
oklahoma kyler murray made his debut
yesterday and early on it looked like it
was not going to go well
for the cardinals and then in the fourth
quarter they woke up it went from 24 to
6 to 24 to 24
and then they had a chance late in the
fourth quarter to drive down the field
and score the touchdown and they did and
the two-point conversion and they did
and the arizona cardinals
force overtime down 24-6 are you kidding
me detroit lions if you're watching on
nbcs under sky sports there's the little
flip i mean that is the poise and calm
of a 15-year veteran seriously the only
problem is the 10 minutes of overtime
expired without anyone scoring and
tremaine brock
did you see the very end tremaine brock
had the ball hit him in the face he had
an interception all i do is step out of
bounds and the and the cardinals could
have tried a long field goal at a time
when the lions were just
using those last few seconds to try to
do anything but chris it was uh it was
amazing to see the cardinals finally
wake up cliff kingsbury the coach the
team said after the game those first
three quarters were pathetic and it's on
me yeah the fourth quarter unbelievable
what they were able to accomplish yeah
uh it was it certainly wasn't an offense
that was never seen before in the
history of the nfl for the through the
first three quarters or the first four
or the whole game it was not first three
quarters it was an offense that should
never be seen yeah right or we've seen
we've been like we were joking we were
like we've seen crap like this many
times before um either way this is it
was a theme a little bit yesterday all
together there's a number of games we
can look at the lions dominated the the
the game play for a long long time but
when you let a team hang around and hang
around this is the nfl eventually guys
are gonna get hot there's too much
talent everything's equal on each side
of the ball and it became a little bit
of a backyard football game there in the
fourth quarter and it suited what what
kyler murray and the arizona cardinals
want to do the lions had the chance to
put the game away late in the game had a
penalty on a big third down which
ultimately led them to punting to the uh
arizona cardinals and that was big but
either way kyla murray uh looks like he
belongs as we thought really it doesn't
really matter the physical ability is
still special when you're up 18 points
you're usually not letting the team hang
around
the lions took their foot off the gas
yeah and let the cars a better way back
it's amazing right and remember i said
the pressure's on matt patricia you got
to show the rest of the nfl that this
gimmicky offense isn't going to work and
for three quarters it didn't but they
got to be able to finish this is not
going to go over well in detroit you
know a tie is still better than the loss
but they had that game oh they blew it
yeah two two different mindsets there i
mean you you that they
they those two teams left that stadium
and the lions felt damn i can't believe
we tied that's a shame it's almost gonna
feel like a loss to them the arizona
cardinals are gonna feel like the
opposite it's like man good thing we got
the tie in that game i mean they're
gonna almost go in with like a little
more of a positive vibe in the into the
building this morning uh which you hope
you know can trickle into next week and
if you're the lions you hope it doesn't
trickle in the next week and next week a
couple of heisman trophy winners get
together
tyler murray and lamar jackson and lamar
jackson my goodness we'll talk about him
coming up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports